if there's one thing that life has
taught me it's that if you make a
mistake you will have to live with that
mistake until you die there is no escape
I remember this one day very vividly
when I was just sitting around minding
my own business until my mum came in
holding a pair of slippers and then she
asked me a question a question that
still strikes fear into my heart she
asked me Charlie what are these
instantly I was just like oh my god this
is a test my mum needs to know that she
has raised a son who can effectively
name a thing when it is placed in front
of them I need to commit myself to this
so I looked her in the eye I pointed at
the slippers and I said flippant which
is not the word for slippers it may have
been a long time since that day occurred
you know it was good 20 years ago now
there was one years old so it's fairly
understandable that I didn't know how to
say the word slippers but you know it
still hurts or whatever regardless of it
being a long time ago it still came back
to haunt me recently in the form of
Charlie's blip-it book for me the word
blip it basically means failure in the
face of my parents but to my parents the
word blip it means funny things that I
used to say when I was a baby and this
book is full of them they're quite
adorable so I thought I'd read you
something actually I do start off fairly
well and this one of the first things
that I apparently said this was when I
was 1 years old I said excuse me darling
which for a one-year-old that's love and
impressive but it just sort of goes
downhill from there for example we have
on record here the first ever song that
I wrote goes like this I still remember
the tune fireman sam had a train
ee i ee i oh and on that train he had a
pig another example of when I didn't
finish something that I was working on
not only that but that's clearly
plagiarism I had no creative integrity
back then there actually a few moments
in this book which reading back just
make me weirdly proud of baby Charlie
like for example I picked up a box of
DUPLO like baby Lego I walked to the
door leaving the room and I said I'm
going to work which as a self-confessed
workaholic just just makes me happy that
that's something I did this is another
one where I'm just incredibly proud of
myself my mum came into the room and
said I've got a bad back and I said does
that mean you've got a happy front I'll
die a happy front I couldn't even think
of that now
Yates even guess what I'm trying to
describe in this sentence it came out in
my mouth on mummys book I was trying to
tell my mother that I had vomited on her
Filofax again proud I don't know why
vomiting I don't know now as well as my
creative integrity apparently being of
low standard I was also apparently quite
sexist when I was little that's not
something I'm proud of a tool but when
one of my parents asked me it's Daisy
your friend
I said no actually Daisy's a girl that
is a perm right that is a toddler berm
right there I think this is easily one
of the most adorable things in this book
so prepare your arse have them ready in
your throat my mum had been ill and so
me and my dad went to go buy our present
and my dad said it's a poorly present
for mummy and I said not a poorly
present a better present I'm so pleased
I wasn't pleasing myself I love baby
charlie as it I hope you enjoyed that
little insight into what baby Charlie
was like and I will see you never again
not really
but feels like that doesn't it my you've
just had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool look at Jack Howard
I do find myself being really proud of
baby Charlie and some of these like
there was this one occasion where
apparently I picked up a box of DUPLO
which is sort of like baby Lego if you
don't know I had to look it up so if you
don't know that's fine why haven't the
infant DUPLO I'm trying to not offend
people who don't know what DUPLO is you
don't know what DUPLO is you're an idiot
deal with it I picked up my DUPLO I
walked out of the room and I said I'm
I'm not gonna use that take